let's get started with this this this is
huge news this is i can't believe it
from globalnews.ca ontario freezes funds
from give send go trucker convoy
fundraiser the ontario government says
it has successfully petitioned a court
to freeze access to millions of dollars
donated through online online
fundraising platform give send go uh my
first question is are they based in
canada and how can you actually stop
this from getting to people you can't
the give send go uh organizers could
just convert it to bitcoin or crypto and
there's nothing anyone could do to stop
them however that would be against this
court order just so you know i don't
know if it's illegal but they're gonna
say the province obtained an order from
the superior court of justice that
prohibits anyone from distributing
donations made through the website's
freedom convoy 2022 and adopt a trucker
campaign pages said a spokesman for
premier doug ford
ivana yelish said the order binding any
and all parties with possession or
control of these donations was issued
thursday afternoon she cited a section
of the criminal code that allows the
attorney general to apply for a
restrained order against any
offense-related property this is really
really amazing stuff i want to show you
this uh this post from andrew lawton
here's a quote says the ontario
government says it has effectively
frozen all donations quote today the
attorney general brought brought an
application in the superior court of
justice for an order pursuant to section
490.8
of the criminal code prohibiting any
person from disposing of or otherwise
dealing with in any manner whatsoever
any and all monetary donations made
through the freedom convoy 2022 and
adopted trucker campaign pages on the
give send go online fundraising platform
this afternoon the order was issued it
binds any and all parties with
possession or control over these
donations
i don't know are the people who have set
the page canadian and i wonder
ultimately if it's if it's gonna matter
yeah well also even if they're not based
in canada the canadian government can
say we'll never let you operate within
the borders of our country again or
something along those lines unless you
surrender the money to us well so here's
what i don't understand right they say
disposing of disposing of so
so if you have these donations and
you're like i'm going to refund them you
can't do that you can't refund them it
says otherwise dealing with what if what
if they came out and said you know well
look if we can't give them the truckers
we're going to give it back to people no
you can't do that either so they're
effectively stealing the money yes
locking it in place that no one can
touch it that's what it sounds like
sounds like despotism yeah well but look
at how these kinds of things go when
blm riots burns down cities gets people
killed absolutely destroys lower class
neighborhoods they are given
federal relief money from jb pritzker
in illinois your taxes end up funding
them when people voluntarily decide that
they want to support working-class
people standing up for their rights as
workers that money is stolen from them
looks like uh gibson goes based out of
boston massachusetts according to
crunchbase.com so i would imagine they
don't really have any any
liability here they can do no no foreign
government can make them do anything uh
but but it's the people who started the
page interesting so that's what they're
in canada
yeah
yeah i just don't i don't understand how
they can do that i don't i don't see how
that works i mean how do they stop them
from
from giving money to somebody that they
want to give money to
i mean what and and who that's right so
so that's why this is it's you know let
me just slow down
holy
they are desperate yes they're they're
saying this money from this fund you
can't do anything with why because how
do they prove the money was given to
someone involved in the trigger convoy
if they if there's a guy named bob smith
and they're like we gave him 500 000
you know they're going to be like well
that's the convoy no it isn't
prove it prove this guy
how yeah and so they just say well then
no one can touch any of the money
well so what happens then if i mean this
is
ultimately i think they're trying to
cause damage to give send go right
well it's gibson go was a you know it's
a christian organization that was
created as a response to gofundme being
so relentlessly left wing and and fun
you know the gosnell movie they started
the
the fundraising campaign to raise money
for the gosnell on gofundme and then
gofundme rejected it
you know said they couldn't raise money
on that platform because of the subject
matter and so they had to go to
indiegogo wow
they've been they've been this way for
years well the thing with gibson go i
mean was my comment earlier off base is
it possible that the canadian government
could legitimately just say to them you
can't operate here unless you surrender
the funds to the company itself yeah
yeah like what other mechanisms yeah
what other mechanism is there right yeah
is what i'm curious about but you're
saying it's a christian company so i
hope that's not the case and i hope they
would stick up for their principles i
don't want to suggest that is what's
happening i have no clue i hope canada
bans give send a go and i don't mean
that literally i mean that like try it
yeah imagine what that would sound like
to the rest of the world canada
bans fundraising platform
for engaging in offenses
wow there this is this is i just got to
say over target yeah kind of kind of
scary actually how effective the trucker
thing is and how panicked they are
they're trying to claim oh far right
right wing all that other garbage and
it's just a bunch of trucks that parked
you know what i mean they're going to
keep claiming it do you guys do you guys
hear that they want to go after their
kids now yeah yeah there was that story
where apparently they are child
endangerment or something if you bring
your kids with you to the content it
didn't work no
so now they're just like give us your
money
it's not going to work it's not going to
work
you know you know what's crazy is it's
really easy to throw a wrench in the
spokes it's really it's really hard to
build an engine it's really easy to
break one yep so you get these guys who
got these big rigs it's not the most
expensive operation ever planned it's
not the most expensive expensive protest
we've ever seen it's just one of the
most effective imagine imagine if there
really is going to be a you know this
like a us trucker convoy or whatever if
truckers just even in small groups
decided we're going to take what we want
from now on they could and no one could
stop them yeah
to me it looks like they really need
something that's less centralized so
they tried um gofundme and now they're
trying give sengo and they're having
kind of the same problems with both
platforms even though gibson go is much
freer than gofundme was it sounds like
they need a way to get these individual
funds to the truckers that need it uh
without going through a central system
am i crazy no you're not if you're using
fiat in any way it's gonna go through a
central service to get to its target
right um the only way to do something
non-centralized here i think if the
present would be with crypto from yeah
that's what it sounds like so we
actually have a statement from give send
go they tweeted
know this
canada has absolutely zero jurisdiction
over how we manage our funds here at
give send go all funds for every
campaign on give send go flow directly
to the recipients of those campaigns not
least of which is the freedom convoy
campaign beautiful
accept good for them if the people who
are getting the money are in canada then
the canadian government's gonna go after
their bank accounts so give send go can
be like yo you can't do anything with
money yeah well yeah the money's flowing
but they're going after the individuals
who are raising the money so i'm
wondering if the people who set it up
are in canada and that's that's the big
question it would be really funny i got
to be honest if the people who set the
page up are not in canada and we're just
like americans who are like we're gonna
we're gonna help fundraise for this
because then canada really is just
having a temper tantrum and they can do
nothing about it nothing
well i'm i'm worried about remember how
they just seized the crypto keys from
the people who were running this kind of
bitcoin scam and i think was new york
city the crocodile wall street or
whatever this lady and her husband
called themselves um so i'm curious if
they're gonna try to use this as a way
to get the whole control of crypto jump
started i wonder if they'll use this as
a way to like well
i just thought last night first time i
thought this i think maybe crypto itself
nakamoto satoshi nakamoto maybe that
that is like a government operation to
get and then they're going to crash the
fiat system and then get everyone on
crypto and then track everybody i mean i
literally said this two years ago it's
finally sinking in today i said it over
and over again thanks doc
yeah i mean you so there's that big
story about the crocodile of wall street
lady right these two people apparently
they're accused of uh
wire fraud stealing hacking you know
billions of dollars in bitcoin
and uh i've been saying this i remember
us hanging out with luke uh from we are
change a few years ago and i was telling
all his buddies and i was like
the ledger is public every crypto
transaction is public so unless you're
using zcash or monero or something but
even then these people who who were got
who got busted
they were using monero and the
government still tracked it it's like
look man you got powerful interests that
are terrified you're going to try and
circumvent the tax base the tax system
they're going to figure out a way to
find out how much money you got and why
so you know ultimately
this this all comes together when you
realize what a um a lot of people on the
right have been talking about what what
cashless society looks like yes yo
you're in it
you know right now i've got you know i
got some cash in my pocket or whatever
if i want to go buy something no one can
take that cash cash from me unless they
come and take it but if you got all your
all your money in a bank account they
could just be like wrong thinker now you
can't buy food right
yeah the other thing we're seeing too
it's kind of like um
as an aside but somewhat related you see
they're having national guard active
substitute teachers yeah national guard
is being deployed to act as teachers
where this in new mexico uh 79 national
guard deployed to be teachers and
they're saying there's going to be more
and i'm just like yo
we're getting to the point where they're
going to steal your money right from
underneath you
imagine what the future looks like when
they can take your money away because
it's digital and they control the banks
and the financial institutions think
about what the future likes when they
issue a universal basic income everybody
gets 2000 a month the private sector has
been destroyed by all these insane
restrictions all that's left are big box
stores where you can buy stuff you get a
funded amount of cash the people working
at those stores are all national guard
sounds a whole lot like communism yes i
heard that there
uh this was just a one person on twitter
said that by 2026 they want to have kill
switches in all cars like remote kill
switches yeah so that if you don't are
you a wrong thinker your car turns off i
don't know yeah i don't know if it's
because if you're a wrong thinker or
something i think it's like a tech
backup or something they don't want
anything to go wrong supposedly they
want it so that when you're running from
cops exactly yeah the cop can press the
button did they just do that didn't they
just hack some guy's gps system and
freeze his car because he was running
from cops i saw a new story about this i
swear you guys can continue it's for
your own good yeah
you're really sounding ungrateful here i
know i know i'm sorry what's your deal
yeah just just accept when the
government decides they know what's best
for you
because um
i think if history has taught us
anything it's that um
you know the government is always
looking out for your best interests and
the police are great i love that meme
where it's like so weak
it's it's a twitter post and the guy's
like
so yeah the cia did bad stuff in the 50s
the 60s the 70s the 80s the 90s the
2000s no one's ever been criminally
charged or held accountable but
we can't assume they're doing anything
wrong now exactly that's a conspiracy
theory yeah
i'm talking to people about how the
government's lying about january 6 i go
oh no they're not i go what what
convinced you that the government wasn't
going to lie to you was it vietnam was
it tuskegee was it
yeah
jfk what was it but this is the thing
you know when i hear
these people arguing with you about it i
just why why even talk to him anymore
it's just i'm i'm so over i'm so beyond
it there there's p the people in the um
i don't know what you call it liberty
side of things
have this tendency to think that they're
playing a fair game of chess right while
the other side is snickering amongst
themselves about how they've been
cheating the whole time yeah massey was
saying last night thomas massey was on
the show congressman and he was saying
that it's like he goes in there he has
to almost forget most of what he knows
about engineering just to participate in
congress because it's so emotionally
charged and people are
like wild animals you know working off
their feelings
yes he didn't say that that's me
interpreting what he said but i i agree
with the emotion thing but it's it's
like it's so much
more raw than you realize
you're talking to a brick wall you know
when when you're talking to someone uh
so i'll give you guys an example and
i'll give a shout out to our good
friends the young turks because they
deserve it huh we love them i just want
to i just want to say too you know anna
kasparian i don't understand why she's
such a mean person she's better than me
i'm told well i mean she's she's just a
mean person and uh
you know i've talked about the young
turks i've talked about a bunch of
people and i'll criticize them but i
always try to keep it to a certain
degree depending on who it is like cnn
they get nothing from me like they're
awful you know all of them i just vile
people uh but um
you know i recently tweeted something
nice to jake uger because he tweeted out
try being nice to someone and see see
how it makes you feel and i was like i i
respect and agree with that so i tweeted
at jenk i was like i think you're a
smart man who's widely successful with
one of the biggest political shows and i
respect your hard work that you put into
this it's all true it's all true the
dude has is wildly successful you don't
gotta like the guy or agree with them to
recognize the thing he's built and he
liked it he clicked the like button on
that so they did this segment we were
talking about january 6th
and uh we had enrique tario one of the
proud boys and uh i had mentioned look
the people at the front gate of the of
the the tunnel entrance of the capitol
and the front entrance where they were
fighting with cops that whole area all
those people okay that was violence that
was a violent riot yeah you get arrested
for that you commit an act of violence
we arrest you those people yeah hands
down we get it you're going to get them
for whatever you get them for
but there were a lot of people who are
the magami maws as we call who are
walking around and then all of a sudden
you see this video of the cops opening
the barricades and fanning people in
so my specific point was
if you're walking down the street and a
police officer goes like this and waves
you in opens up the barricades you are
not trespassing you are not legally
trespassing in any circumstance now the
prosecutors here might lie and just
claim we don't care what the reality is
that's called tyranny but if uh let's
say it's not the capital let's say my
house has a barricade up and you're
walking on the street and i open the
barricade and wave you in
i cannot then attack you and claim you
trespassed what if there's so so hold on
let me finish this point so
when i tell this story and i said that
the people who entered in under the
circumstances
i don't see how you can even get them
for trespassing what ends up happening
is you know anna kasparian makes this
whole video where the one thing i just
don't understand is she's like i she
accuses me of saying these things
knowing it's false because i just want
to make money
they then try to allege that because
other people on the other side of the
building were fighting with cops that
means the other people on the other side
of the building who are led in by the
cops are committing crimes yeah and i'm
just like that's that's the point of
you know i don't bring them up
to actually engage in any meaningful
dialogue with them because they don't
want to no because i've politely asked
them because i have
jenk on dm i message him and i'm like
hey we'd love to talk like let's talk
they won't do it they have no interest
whatsoever and having real conversations
i'm not gonna insult them i will i will
i literally just complimented the man's
work but instead what they do is they
make they make insults they insult my
appearance they don't engage with the
core of what the actual statement or
argument is so at this point with all of
this stuff going on i just say the only
thing that matters right now that these
people are interested is power they
don't care about truth they don't care
about arguments it's power and if you if
we if we as the libertarian side of
things i don't mean big al i mean just
the more freedom oriented people keep
saying why won't they understand maybe
if we keep trying to convince them to
understand they do understand they're
lying about it
look
i sent i tweeted anna i commented on
their video i dm with periodically
saying let's talk and i said what i said
was a specific reference to a story from
abc news where the defendants in the
case on january 6 said the police let us
in and told us it was okay
and and and my point is if that is
discernibly discernibly true
you can't prosecute on trespassing in
most in any circumstance i mean there's
probably some technicalities instead of
actually taking the core of that
argument she just says tim's lying for
money he's a grifter he knows he's lying
and they totally misrepresent the
entirety of the conversation there's no
point in arguing with these people so
right now at a point where this country
is so far divided
there's there's just you are wasting
your time when you should be doing
grassroots organizing some kind of
effective
growth strategy there's an old saying
that when you argue with a fool there
are two i do think there's one exception
here
if someone says something ridiculous
like this to you and then you respond
and you have a reasonable argument
the moderates will see that
and they will be more likely to take
your side the future if the person
you're arguing with responds to your
reasonable response in bad faith then i
think you just have to discontinue the
conversation and then they look like a
fool because if you respond to their bad
faith then you look like an idiot
because you look like you're because
honestly you look like you're reacting
emotionally because you know you can't
reason with this person you're only
continuing with the argument because you
want your ego to come out on top you're
not going to win you're right it's like
playing chess with a pigeon they're
going to knock the pieces off what is
the board take a crap and start around
winning isn't like i was right or you
were right because we're both probably
right the same thing differently no no
dude dude
in this specific context there is a
video you can watch of the police
opening the barricades and fanning
people my question is if if there's a
cop on your driveway and you had a no
trespassing sign and they were waving
people in
again and you didn't know would those
people not be trespassing then because
the cop waved well but but that if it's
if it was a police officer charger if it
was a security agent specifically
charged with protecting the parameter
like the capital police are specifically
charged to protect that parameter and
they were the ones letting people and
they were the ones holding the
barricades so let me let me make this
point okay they opened the barricades up
there's video of it there's numerous
videos and multiple officers fanning
people in now the argument is they were
fanning the officers back saying retreat
because the mob was pushing too hard the
mob didn't break the barriers down the
cops opened them up and that was at
least at one entrance you have to
understand that when it comes to
criminal law an individual as an
individual on january 17th 2020 the the
the police in dc tried charging antifa
with as a group under conspiracy it
doesn't work you can't do it under our
legal system that means each individual
in that crowd gets an individual charge
now there's some circumstances where you
get racketeering you get people as a
group there's numerous videos of that
there's a there's another video where
the doors are actually opened by the
police and one guy goes i don't know man
they're going to trap us inside because
the police opened the door and then one
officer says i don't agree with it but i
respect it now if you're walking into a
building and a cop says that how could
could you be criminally prosecuted under
trespassing when trespassing requires
you know you trespassed and i'll give
you the specific example is
when we had the police here
talking to them the officer told us if
you don't have a sign if it's just a
driveway the public is allowed to enter
you can then tell them to leave and they
have to if they don't then it's
trespassing by placing the sign
now it's trespassing and it is true at
the capitol there were many signs except
not everywhere and many of them were
taken down and the police even removed
some of those barricades and you're in
the home um situation you have to have a
sign on the driveway because what if
they walk onto your property
we're not going to get into that this is
my question that guarantees they see it
as if it's on the in the entrance but if
they enter from a different area and
they don't see a sign is it still
testing even though there's a sign yes
so you're supposed to assume they're
supposed to enter from the driveway
it's a pointless i'm sorry you're on the
front door or something if you're if
you're sneaking through the woods to get
on a property or trespass and there's no
argument if someone if someone some
people walk i know it's not common but
i'm just wondering for technicality so
uh you would have to trespass on someone
else's property to trespass on a
property without going through normal
means there's no argument thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you